[Music]
what a pleasure it is to see you all uh
what a pleasure it is to be here uh but
most of all what a pleasure it is
to introduce to you this afternoon
someone who
has
encouraged millions of people millions
of young people in particular
to probe
evaluate ask
questions
that are more fundamental than any other
questions
with which every one of us is confronted
at some point
questions involving meaning
uh identity relationship dignity
what it is to flourish
as a person
he doesn't pretend to have all the
answers
but anyone who has tried walking with
him
the length of king's parade
here in cambridge
in less than half an hour
will know that he seems to be asking the
right questions
and he seems to be reaching
young minds and young hearts
in ways
that
very few other academics in the world
that i can think of
come anywhere close to doing
he's here in
england for a couple of weeks and for
most of those two weeks he's going he
has been and will continue to be here in
cambridge we are lending him to the
other place for a day or two
and
as part of that visit he has been
through uh what have been at least up
until now
i'll be frank with you some pretty
grueling and critical
seminars research seminars on his work
and he has opened himself up to
criticism he has been receptive to it he
has responded to it
uh in an exemplary fashion
uh he has also uh taken part in a public
lecture one last night at gondolin keys
hosted by dr arif ahmed uh here tonight
the flagship event
uh at the university uh he'll be
speaking the cambridge union uh tomorrow
at
the
other union on thursday and westminster
next week and
in accepting
this invitation to come to cambridge
he has i think showed
uh shown extraordinary graciousness
uh towards an institution that has
not been as welcoming to him in the past
as it might have been
who is our speaker he is the professor
emeritus of psychology at the university
of toronto uh he is a clinical
psychologist he's the author of maps of
meaning the architecture of belief 1999
he's the author uh most famously perhaps
of the popular work 12 rules for life in
2018 that has sold
many millions of copies and has topped
bestsellers lists in brazil and
netherlands and the united states and
australia and in too many other
countries
to mention
and in the ruins of the multiversity he
is building a metaversity
uh his lectures online these long
conversations with public commentators
religious leaders
journalists artists
are mesmerizing millions of people a
week
and in doing that i believe he is part
of a movement that is doing nothing less
than widening the horizons
of the humanities
in
the modern world
ladies and gentlemen dr jordan peterson
well thank you very much for the kind
welcome and all the kind words it's been
really
remarkable
to be here it's such a wonderful place
and i hope you all know that
and it's so beautiful and so deep and so
rich and
in the best possible way and it's been
so welcoming and
it's such a privilege
it's an unbelievable privilege to have
that happen
so i thank all of you and for your
attendance today as well and so
we're going to try to work our way
through a problem
today
it's a problem i've
been attempting to wrestle with for a
very long time and
in one way or another
whether we know it or not
we're all wrestling with it
and it's the problem of perception
um
five decades ago i suppose
the problem made itself
explicitly manifest
at a deeper level than it ever had
before although philosophers had
wrestled with this problem for a very
long period of time and part of the
problem was
how much do we bring
to the act of perception and imagination
and thought
and how much
is revealed to us by what we perceive
we thought we understood that i would
say
well enough to make practical progress
after the second world war
but there were doubts that bedeviled
people operating in all sorts of
disciplines that became as i said
increasingly explicit in those decades
and i think for me the most
remarkable revelation of the problem
probably occurred in the world of
artificial intelligence
i learned about this
when i was studying
models of cognitive processes that were
initially generated by russian
investigators like
sokolov and vinogradova who were very
well-known names in the russian
neuropsychological literature which is a
very
academically impressive literature they
were students of luria i think both
vinogradova and
sokolover studies students of luria who
is perhaps the greatest
neuropsychologist of the last
mid part of the 20th century
they were
convinced to some degree that we built
internal models of the world
and then compared what was going on in
the world to those models
stokolov
discovered a phenomenon called the
orienting reflex which was
the an
electrophysiological response to error
detection or response to novelty that's
another way of thinking about it and he
should have won a nobel prize for that
because discovering the instinctual
basis of the response to novelty that's
no small thing there's a lot of novelty
in the world
and sokolov really mapped that in some
sense mapped that onto the body and onto
the nervous system in a way that
superseded what philosophers had done
before that because it made it much more
concrete and tied it down to the
underlying neural architecture
so for example if you're walking down
the road and you uh
there's a loud noise behind you and the
noises of indeterminate meaning so
perhaps a car has jumped a curb that's a
possibility
you'll go like that and stop and turn
and orient towards
the
the place in the space-time continuum
where your stereo vision has localized
the noise and you do that really without
thinking i would say it's an act that
occurs outside the domain of free will
and the reason you do that is because
you might die if something unexpected
happens right something that's outside
your framework of expectation
now you know your framework of
expectation you're an ignorant creature
you don't know
everything you don't even know that much
and your
representation of the world is actually
rather shallow and
low resolution it's good enough to get
you where you want to go most of the
time
but sometimes it isn't and sometimes
it's error written enough given the
circumstances of time and place
that the error will kill you
and so you're equipped with instinctual
mechanisms that orient you towards the
source of the revelation of your
ignorance
and that's something very interesting to
contemplate i would say physiologically
and neurophysiologically but also
philosophically and i would also say to
some degree theologically right that you
have an instinct that orients you
to the source of your ignorance and you
better have an instinct like that
because
there may be a shortage of knowledge but
there's no shortage of ignorance
and so and that's you know part of the
problem of the relationship between the
finite and the infinite right i mean
we're finite creatures we can't know
everything we can't even know as much as
we need to know and that means in some
sense we have to be able to deal with
the fact that we don't know enough
and one of what sokolov outlined at
least in part was the underlying
neurophysiological mechanisms that made
this orienting reflex possible
one way you can measure it for example
is a
if you
if you put on a
gadget a galvan galvanometer on
someone's finger
and you play them a sequence of tones
when you play them the first tone
they'll show quite a response and then
the second tone lesser and after that
lesser until finally it'll flat line
and people thought about that as
habituation but the more sophisticated
cognitive scientists regarded it as the
building of an internal internal model
of the stimulus in all its varieties of
parameters interesting word stimulus
we'll return to that and then if you
play someone a different tone after
habituating them to that sequence the
electrophysiological response will
reinstantiate itself or even if you dif
you you alter the spacing between the
tones the same thing will happen and
that's all part of this response to
novelty and then the mapping of novel
territory this is unbelievably important
this discovery because
you don't
learn anything except by encountering it
as novelty first so it's fundamentally
the initial processes of everything you
do to learn everything there is to learn
everywhere all the time
and so like i said he should have won a
nobel prize but people really didn't
understand the fundamental significance
of this discovery and a very influential
line of
of english british neuropsychology
emerged out of that because a gentleman
named jeffrey gray who was the
most outstanding student i would say of
hans i think who is the most cited
psychologist research psychologist in
the world for
pretty much the last half of the 20th
century jeffrey gray wrote an incredibly
brilliant book called the
neuropsychology of anxiety where he
integrated the work the russians had
done which very few people knew about
apart from gray who read absolutely
everything by the neuropsychology of
anxiety i think cited 300 scientific
deep scientific papers
neurophysiological papers animal
behavioral papers like hardcore
psychology because there is such a thing
and he actually read all those papers
and he actually understood them and then
he integrated that with norbert weiners
who was one of the fathers of
cybernetics and computer science he
integrated that with norbert weiner's
cybernetic theory and with well a raft
of
of animal experimental material and laid
out the neurological basis for the
establishment of the orienting reflex
and also for the establishment of memory
itself it's a tour de force that book
was written in 1982 and psychologists
have really only begun to digest the
material in that book
so
i read it when i was well back in about
1982 very soon that was 85 i guess
very soon after it was published it took
me like six months to read it because
well i had to learn
animal physiology and
neuropsychopharmacology and animal
behavioral science and cybernetic theory
and just along the way to understand
what he was talking about you know it's
a profound work of philosophy i would
say
it's probably a necessary work of modern
philosophy because we're starting to
understand the underlying physiological
substructure of many of the processes
that have been discussed in the
philosophical realm for forever
and so
okay so what what does this have to do
with this problem well
back to the ai researchers so
stemming from sokolov's work at least in
part was the idea that
there's the world out there and it's
made out of objects and they're sort of
self-evident but and what we do is we
build an internal model of that world
and then we compute trajectories we make
maps we compute trajectories we lay out
plans that constitute a manipulation of
that internal representation
and then we act out the representation
and it's kind of an empirical idea
philosophically speaking and the idea is
that sense data is in some sense given
to us and from that sense data that
given
self-evident sense data we build these
models and
and then that's how we think and that's
how we operate in the world and everyone
that's kind of folk psychology everybody
thinks well that's that's right that's
how it is it's no
no
it's not right
at all
and that's why we don't have general
purpose robots
because what happened to the aai
researchers was that
they tried to build machines that and
built toy environments so imagine you're
trying to build a basic robot at least
initially you can't model the whole
world
so you build toy environments that the
that the ai system can model and then
you have it do simple things in the toy
environment you couldn't even get the
machines to see the toy environment
since part of what was discovered in ai
was there were no toy environments
well imagine even if you just have a
like a simple environment that's made
out of uh pyramids and and and columns
spheres just simple geometric forms
well you still have the problem of
variant lighting it's like
well is a pyramid in the morning the
same as a pyramid
at midday
what about five minutes
past midday or
three seconds past midday like how much
lighting how much illumination change is
necessary before the object isn't the
same object
well maybe illumination doesn't have
anything to do with the object well
that's kind of awkward because
then you don't get to see it
and how is it that we managed to infer
the stability of an object to cross
transformations of illumination and the
answer is
we don't know
and how is it that we're able to
perceive objects at all because the
other thing that became complicated and
you see this if you ever use a program
like photoshop you know you can see
objects in a photo in photoshop
and the objects appear self-evident they
have boundaries and borders but if you
zoom in
you can't tell where the boundaries are
they fade into all the other images that
are behind or ahead or or wherever they
happen to be uh displayed and then while
the image is quite different if it's
black and white and then you can
highlight the colors and expand them and
so there's an endless number of things
you can do with the single image of
anything well you think about what that
means there's an endless number of
things you can do with a single image of
anything
well
how in the world is perception possible
then
and the answer is
we didn't know
while at the same time approximately the
same time
the same problem emerged in
literary criticism
and you can see why in some sense right
if you can't
perceive something even simple
in some canonical manner
that's self-evident
how in the world can you derive
a single reliable canonical
interpretation of a given text
and then you could multiply the problem
you say well it's bad enough for a
single text or maybe a single paragraph
or even a sentence
because sentences are amenable to
multiple interpretations
and complex sentences in the beginning
are susceptible to
an endless number of interpretations
really
endless
well endless is a problem right because
to perceive something there has to be an
end
so endless is a real problem and the
cognitive psychologist met in an aguilar
who worked at mit they said a finite
number of objects can be grouped in a
near infinite number of ways
while you think well
imagine your shell your books on a
bookshelf well you have the books and
then you have the sequence of books you
think that's all self-evident how are
you going to arrange those books
well that's a problem if you've ever
tried to sort out your library and if
it's a big library it's a big problem
right you have to invent a very complex
and sophisticated indexing system to
know where the books are
well
the books on your shelf you think well
there's not come on really there's not a
near infinite number of ways to arrange
them what what are you talking about and
that's only the axiomatic self that's
the axiomatic structure of your a prior
perceptions manifesting itself as
self-evident fact to your ignorant mind
because that claim is actually wrong so
you might say well color
thickness
density
age how about thickness of paper
how about
the thickness of the
spot exactly half an inch below
the 35th page in the third chapter
and you think well that's a stupid way
of
organizing your books and i would say
well how do you know it's stupid exactly
and not sort of
right because you can't just claim
self-evidence in this situation because
the self-evidence of the stupidity of
that categorical structure is actually
the mystery
and it's the mystery that say
post-modernists encountered when they
were trying to
specify the canonical meaning of a text
just a single text a single paragraph a
single sentence there's a multiplicity
of potential interpretations even worse
there's a multiplicity of potentially
valid interpretations and so how do you
do anything but throw up your hands and
say
well there is no
solution to that problem
we
or at least and this would be better
we have no idea how we solve this
problem and what would even be better
would be we have no idea how we solved
it in the past
and say that's particularly germane when
you think not even necessarily so much
about the interpretation of a given text
let's say the bible to take a complex
you know problem
but the canon of texts itself now the
canon of texts the fact that there's
canon of text
roughly speaking we can we have agreed
in the past to some degree on the
boundaries of that category although
there's plenty of cognitive activity
around the edges trying to decide what
would fit in and what wouldn't which is
exactly what happened for example when
people were trying to aggregate the
biblical corpus across time because the
bible is of course a library of books
what's in and what's out why is it in
why is it out well the answer to how we
answer that is we don't know how we
answer that and there's this process of
deliberation let's say that is part and
parcel of the process that gives rise to
the to the aggregation of a library of
texts into a corpus
but
we don't really understand the mechanism
we don't understand the mechanism at all
and that's actually all fine except that
we don't have general purpose robots yet
although
they probably are more or less
around the corner in about five years
partly because the ai researchers solved
this problem and part of the way they
solved it was by embodying cognition
incarnating artificial intelligence in
an embodied structure and the first
people to really
propose that that was absolutely
necessary i don't necessarily know the
first people but i know that an mit
researcher named rodney brooks who by
the way invented the roomba some of you
may have a roomba and it's kind of a
laughable little object but but not
really
because it can sort of move around your
house without falling down the stairs
and
your two-year-old can't do that so the
roomba isn't nothing right and brooks
was one of the first people who really
recognized that
to solve the problem of perception we
would have to duplicate the process of
evolution in in hardware and so he
started building these little machines
that pretty much all they did to begin
with was scoot away from light
and well eventually that became the
roomba which is a pretty useful gadget
and you see variance in some sense of
what he's done with self-driving cars
because they're embodied systems as well
right because the car is actually a body
that moves from place to place and it
turns out that a lot of our perceptions
require embodiment and it turns out that
one of the philosophical
consequences implications of that is
that the way we solved the problem of
perception was through 3.5 billion years
or thereabouts of evolution and also
that there was no other way of possibly
solving it
and so
that's a testimony to the power of
evolutionary thinking i would say but
even more a testimony to the power to
the power of the process of evolutionary
development and you might think that
that reduces human cognition to
something sterile and mechanistic
because many of the proponents of the
notion of natural selection have
adopted a fairly reductive materialism
to account for the process of of natural
selection and we're going to talk about
that a little bit
tonight too i hope
if i can manage to tie all these things
together
so
no
perception without embodiment that's
pretty interesting that and so i i could
tell you i'll tell you a little side
neuropsychological story so
you know we tend to think that when we
see the world well there the world is
and then we see the world and we see the
objects and there the objects are but
that isn't how it works and i i've tried
to explain why because there's an
infinite number of ways of perceiving
even the simplest of visual scenes and
and then there's auditory scenes and
then there's the problem of smell and
there's the problem of touch i mean
these are hard problems which is why it
took you know three billion years to
solve them
there's a condition called utilization
behavior it's got an interesting
neuropsychological condition
and generally if if it is affected
right-handed people that's relevant here
because of lateralization if you have
left prefrontal damage you sometimes
will engage in
utilization behavior and
what happens if you're afflicted by this
neuropsychological condition is that you
lose the ability to inhibit your motor
response to the presentation of an
object
now that's worth thinking about even
though it doesn't sound like it's
something that's necessarily worth
thinking about because what do you mean
motor response to an object
because we think object
thought motor response but that's not
how it works
the object itself announces its utility
in the perception
and so what that means is that your eyes
which
map let's say patterns of arrays that's
a good that's a good way of thinking
about it
they map that onto your visual system
and but part of your visual system is
actually your
your motor output system and so that
when i look at let's say this this
bottle
you think i think bottle
hand grip drink
but seeing bottle is hand grip and hand
grip is drink and so if you have
utilization behavior you lose the
ability to inhibit the motor response to
the object and so if you had this
condition i put a cup in front of you
you would pick it up and drink from it
and if you walk down a hallway
and there's a door open you will go
through the door and it's not because
you see the object door and think door
and then think walk through and then
walk through even though that's what you
think you think it's that door is a walk
through place
and if you lack inhibition you can't
stop acting out the perception and so
what that implies is that at some direct
level and this is the science not the
philosophy you don't see objects and
infer meaning you see meaning
and infer
objects and that's really something
you can think about that for like 40
years
because it looks like it's true
factually and that's a strange thing too
right it's very strange
claim to say that the facts support the
notion that the primary object of
perception is meaning not objects
and i actually think that's an
interpretation though i won't go into
that tonight
that's more in keeping with evolutionary
logic than the idea that that you
perceive objects and infer meaning and
so the stripping away of meaning
metaphysically from the world of a
perception that's a consequence of
scientism is actually predicated on
something approximating
bad science
and that's become increasingly evident i
would say in the neurophysiology of
perception and that's an important field
given that the problem of perception is
the problem that has bedeviled
both the sciences and the humanities and
also in the also engineering for that
matter for the last 50 years and it has
not only done that it's produced this
rivening of culture
that's occurred within the universities
partly because of the post-modernist
claim
and so fundamental post-modernist claims
now the first claim is that there's
there's no canonical interpretation that
self-evidence like okay fair enough fair
enough that's that might be a claim
emerging from
literary departments english literary
departments under the influence of
french continental thought let's say
um
i don't think you can take issue with
that i think it happens to be the case
because the notion that there is a
multiplicity of potentially valid
interpretations is true
what isn't true is the idea that we use
power and domination to solve that
problem primarily
and there's no excuse philosophically
from leaping from a mystery that's
utterly profound which is the problem of
perception to the conclusion
that some pathological socially
constructed process is therefore at the
basis of the act of perception and
categorization itself
i think that's
i think it's unforgivable
cognitively
and it's cynical beyond belief
and it's corrosive beyond our capacity
to deal with it
i mean you think about what that claim
means is that
the way you solve the and that's like an
implicit bias argument by the way just
to make that clear as well that you
solve the problem of categorization by
imposing your will to power on the world
in some
zero-sum winner-take-all game of
dominion
and and uh and oppression
it's like you could not if you tried you
could not come up with a more cynical
view of the mechanism that makes
order habitable order out of chaos
and but what's sort of delightful about
that in some sense is that it's just not
true
it's literally
we could say scientifically if we
take
scientifically to mean literally we can
say
it's not true
it actually turns out that even in the
animal kingdom we know you might think
the hierarchies that we use to orient
ourselves in
that's part of the strategy that we use
to guarantee our survival you know we
fight tooth and nail
with nature red and claw to climb the
hierarchies of dominance as a
consequence of our will to power
it's like
no
actually
that isn't how it works
and so
we all have this image for many of us i
would say have an image of
chimpanzee troops let's say our closest
primate relative we split from them
in evolutionary terms about seven
million years ago something like that
you can calculate that quite accurately
by looking at the
mutation rate of
of of genetic material that we share
with chimps and calculate the average
mutation rate and look at the the
propagation of mutations and the
separation of them you can get a pretty
accurate estimate of the split it's a
long time ago
um so we're pretty tightly
related to chimpanzees and we know that
we all know that the biggest toughest
meanest
male oppressive chimp rules the troop
it's like
no
wrong
friends to all has studied dominance
hierarchies so-called dominance
hierarchies
and that's an interesting
issue that that is the term that's most
often used dominance hierarchy because
you might ask as a very intelligent
student of mine once did just exactly
where did that term come from and how
much political implication was loaded in
that right from the beginning i thought
about that for about five years i
thought it was an unbelievably i mean
that i thought it was an unbelievably
acute observation he was a very
is a very acute fellow
so
the brute chimpanzees they have a pretty
short
tyrannical rule
and the reason for that is
i don't care how big and tough and mean
and dominant and oppressive you are two
slightly less mean oppressive and
dominant males
can take you out pretty easily on a bad
day
and that's a real problem you think
about that biologically that's that's a
non-trivial problem
and so that is exactly what happens in
chimpanzee troops is that the
males who rise to a position of
authority as a mere consequence of their
psychopathic will to power
rule very unstably over very unstable
troops and have a very short ruling
period
whereas the males that manage to because
in chimps the the fundamental hierarchy
is male dominated it's that's less
obvious in another set of very close
primate relatives the baltimores
they're more female dominated
interestingly enough and it isn't
obvious
which of those two species were more
like so but i'll concentrate on the
chimps now because we're talking a
little bit about will to power
the males who manage to maintain a
relatively stable
coalition let's say are actually very
affiliative in fact they groom
other males more
than
any other males in the troop and so
they're doing they're using reciprocal
altruism at least in part as the basis
of their claim to dominion now they do
have preferential mating access to
females and that there's there's some
analogy in that with what happens in the
human case but it's more complicated in
the human case in any case they also
tend to spend a fair bit of time
attending to the females in the troop in
a positive way and to their infants and
so the more benevolent but still
physically able males seem to establish
a stable social hierarchy that's quite
unlike the social hierarchy that's
produced by the you know more
psychopathic straight you know raw will
to power
and
well and here's another fact for what
it's worth
if the
hierarchy that we use to aggregate the
canon
is fundamentally predicated on
oppressive power
which is the claim
then why do psychopaths only constitute
three percent of the population
and that's actually stable and so
they're good evolutionary biology
psychology models of psycho psychopathy
its emergence has been modeled quite
emergency stability has been modeled
quite nicely in computer simulations and
such simulations can be used as
appropriate models if the psychopath
prevalence falls below one percent
there's so few of them that people get
complacent
in relationship to the possibility of
malevolence and so then they can
flourish a bit right and their
prevalence can rise in the population
but if it gets up to five percent it's
like everybody wakes up and it's not
such a good day for the psychopaths when
they do
and uh
and somebody has to keep the malevolent
types down
you know and that's probably
possibly possible will say
why women like men who are less
agreeable than they are
you know and women have to solve this
very complex mating problem in
relationship to men which is
there are bad men they're really bad
and they're a minority of the population
and they tear their way through
overly agreeable populations
and to keep them from dominating you
need good men who are also capable of
being quite terrible
and so that's
appears to be
the conundrum that women face when
they're choosing male partners one of
the conundrums they want someone who's
strong enough
to resist what's truly terrible but
benevolent and generous enough to
and productive enough to be productive
and useful
but also agreeable and empathic enough
to share and you can see that that's a
terribly tight line right and women are
always well young women tend to
overshoot the mark in
on the malevolent side so so the
psychopathic machiavellians who
mimic competent male behavior
they ape it so to speak
are pre are differentially attractive to
young and inexperienced women whereas
women who've had some experience get
better at distinguishing the
psychopathic machiavellian pretenders
who often manifest a certain confidence
in a certain bravado bravado they uh
they get good at distinguishing them
from the real thing
and so it's a tricky thing for women to
manage and men can use deceptive
strategies to mimic competence which is
exactly what deceptive strategies are
for
obviously and and that's also a pathway
to short-term mating success under some
circumstances and it's viable enough to
propagate itself in the population but
it's not a good medium to long-term
strategy
and the question might be well
what is a good medium to long-term
strategy and it looks like something
well that is the question that's
actually at the bottom of this entire
talk because
it's also
the same question as
what is the process
that gives rise to perception itself
this is an attempt to integrate across a
whole variety of complex questions
so
you might ask yourself
this is where it gets difficult to tie
all these things together
so let me see how i'm going to be able
to do this
yes there's no evidence as far as i can
tell that the proposition
that the fundamental motivation for
categorization itself
is
the expression of power
that seems wrong it's not stable
so then the question is well what is
exactly at the base of the process of
perception and categorization and so
that would be really right at the basis
of
cognition itself
perhaps the essence of consciousness
itself
and certainly the thing that acts at the
interface between what is not yet known
and what is going to be known right the
active investigation
that transforms what's unexpected and
potentially dangerous into what's
habitable safe competent and secure
i saw this opera
but you didn't think i was going there
i saw this opera in new york city about
three weeks ago
uh
opera written by a dead white male of
the oppressive sort uh
wagner and so he's sort of ways way up
there on that list man
and it was the opera meister singer and
it was really interesting the libretto
was really interesting it it really
dovetailed in a strange way with the
sorts of things i happen to be writing
about at that point and i'll just run
through it quickly and hopefully that
will help tie together these strands
that i've laid all over the place now so
while music does that right it ties
things together great art does that it
ties things together and so
and it's part of the process by which we
make order out of chaos right great art
not power great art and you have to be
so cynical that it beggars description
and so envious of what's great to
reflexively identify that with the will
to power i mean really
that's what you think when you enter one
of the great cathedrals or chapels that
are
the grace your campus
you think nothing but will to power
erected that
corrupt oppression
and if you do think that well what do
you think of yourself then you think
you're nothing but the expression of the
corrupt will to power or you somehow
circumvented that because of your moral
piety and well in what case in that case
then what is it you're relying on
to orient yourself in the world
it's something other than that will to
power
well if so then exactly what it is what
is it
well you come to university to ally
yourself with the forces of great art
let's say
and that's so much more powerful than
mere power that they're not even in the
same category
well back to die meister singer so it's
very interesting opera because
it it uh it's set in nuremberg
in nuremberg in the opera there are
these guilds of men
and they're all craftsmen and so one of
the heroes of the story there's two
heroes and heroine in in the story
he's a cobbler
and he's a really good cobbler and you
think
well he's just a cobbler it's like it
was so funny because when i went to see
this opera my shoes were didn't fit i
had these shoes that i hadn't really
paid attention to for like three years
and my feet were just killing me and i
was in this opera and it emphasized the
absolute moral necessity of attending to
your shoes properly and i thought huh
isn't that synchron synchronous we'll
say and it it certainly was and now i
have shoes that fit although they're
still these are somewhat ugly but they
do at least fit so i partially solved
the problem
in any case
dei meister singer is the master singer
and so these men that are all extremely
skilled craftsmen
so they're people who have skill right
at the level of the interface with the
world
they get together in guilds of their own
type
and then they also practice singing and
one of them who's a skilled craftsman
because that's a prerequisite is elected
as a master singer and so each of these
guilds have master singers
and now and then they elect a new master
singer and all the master singers get
together to elect a new master singer
i was thinking about this this little
trope i'd already written down in the
book i'm writing while i was watching
this i you know this you see this and if
you watch american sports films you know
so
um
there's a football team and
after
overcoming great odds the quarterback
who's probably
you know risen above his suffering in
some manner
triumphantly
produces the victory and
all the other football players
put him up on their shoulders and lead
them out of the stadium and everybody's
standing up and cheering and
then he
has an affair with his girlfriend the
top cheerleader and everyone leaves
happily ever after and
and that's the same motif as the as the
meister singer right it's really
interesting you know that the men will
put that other man on their shoulders
it's not that's not a good long-term
mating strategy that right to elevate
him above you in that sort of
competition but men do that all the time
interestingly enough and in in dei
meister singer
the men in the guilds come together
and a new
entrant onto the
potential master stinger stage
comes into the town and he's a knight
and he's wandered through nature and
he's things of nature but he's
completely undisciplined he doesn't know
any of the rules and so he's not a
master craftsman like these craftsmen
but he wants to be a master singer
simultaneously one of the other leaders
of the guilds offers his entire fortune
and the hand of his daughter to the new
master singer and you think well that's
a pretty patriarchal trope but it's
actually handled extraordinarily
brilliantly i think within the confines
of the arp because she is the heroine of
the story and although her father is
offering her one of the masters
um
she has the right of choice
and and it's not sort of it's she has
the choice a little bit it's clearly
part of the opera that she has the
choice
and she falls in love with this knight
it's hardly a surprise but
women are perverse like that
and uh
but the master's thing is they don't
know what to do with this guy because
he's unbelievably gifted in terms of his
talent but
he's not a master he's not a craftsman
he hasn't gone through the disciplinary
process that would mold him into someone
who's
thoroughly united right from the bottom
of the craft to the tip of the head
and so they're thrown into disarray by
this and also by the fact that this
woman
her instinct drives her towards him
and so
they did degenerate the men's skills
degenerates into kind of an internecine
squabble
and it's complicated by the fact that
the woman also kind of like some of the
other master singers they're older
they're competent
and so they have a shot at her hand
and so
they fall into disarray under the stress
of this mating competition we could say
that biologically
and
the cobbler who's the paramount hero in
the story
who the woman loves
but perhaps not as much as the knight
and he's old he's like 55 so he's
younger than me but he's too old you
know this is a young woman
and so he decides he's going to train
this young knight
and that's pretty damn interesting you
know because he thinks
the moral thing to do here
is to take myself out of the competition
and to
raise this untutored but extraordinarily
talented young man man to a position of
primacy to unite
nature and culture simultaneously in his
form
and to help him attain the status of
master singer
and his name is johan
sax
and johan is john
and he's john the baptist
and i'm not just inventing that it's not
just my
patriarchal power driven
inference on
the multiplicity of potential meanings
in the text because
wagner basically says that in the
lobreto and a few times in case you
don't catch it the first time
and so in some manner this knight
is christ
and that's a strange thing
but you know you can understand it right
it doesn't it's not like it doesn't make
sense in some sense because christ is
always presented as a super ordinate
ideal and obviously this new master
singer who unites the melody of nature
and the discipline of culture is
is
is a master of his craft
by divine grace because of his talent
but also now because han sucks it's han
sacks that's johan that's john the
baptist
decides to train him and so now he's a
model of discipline
and craft
and that's allied with natural talent
and that gives a whole new depth to his
voice because now that natural talent
has been properly brought under a
disciplined structure which is a
reflection of the guild structure of the
entire meistersinger contest and suffice
it to say that
sax pulls himself out of the race and
and
decides to sacrifice himself in some
sense for this young man and the woman
chooses the night and the knight
undergoes this disciplinary regimen and
then he sings in the contest and all the
master singers now can
um
what would you say live comfortably with
their conscience and they elect him to
the highest position and then
sax and the knight and the woman are
celebrated it's lovely brilliant and
then of course it's set to this
remarkable music and watch all these
people who spent all these years
disciplining themselves in some
unbelievably difficult manner to play
their instruments properly and to
interact with each other harmoniously
and to play while they're doing it so
that it's not just wrote and
and and to produce this magnificent
stage in this ridiculous building this
ridiculously impressive building in this
unbelievably impressive city and all
these people come there and devote their
attention to watching this
well why
why
why indeed
well that master singer spirit
that's what solves the problem of
perception
it's not raw power
right it's not a corrupt will
it's not a satanic force
it's exactly the opposite of that
and you know we all know that we all
know that although we don't know we know
it
you know
i was in the chapel the other day here
which one was it you have two remarkable
chapels well more than two but two
particularly remarkable chapels um
doesn't matter
really
up on the
pinnacle of the
chapel interior there's a picture of
christ and it's like a byzantine
representation he's in a mandola which
is a shape that freudians can have no
shortage of fun with and
he's he's he's shining forth from this
background and he's placed above the sky
right or on the sky and you see this
even more clearly in byzantine
church architecture so
the cathedral is a cross and then at the
central point of the cross so that's the
point of maximal suffering right that's
what's being illustrated in the
architecture there's a dome
and the dome is
well how about it's the sky it's not
that hard to figure out and the
cathedral structure is trees
and so it's a it's a representation of
our primordial environment this
ancient forest right which is now
recreated in stone with this dome that's
above all that's centered at the point
of the cross which is the point
of maximal suffering
and
you look up into the sky
the starry firmament and what do you see
reflected
back down
to you
you see this image of the divine word
that's what you see
you might not even know that you're
seeing that you don't know you're in a
forest you don't know you're seeing the
sunlight filter through the branches
you know our ancestral home for
millions tens of millions of years you
don't see the immense labor and effort
that it took to erect that cathedral and
to put that image in its highest place
at least she dressed like a lobster
so that was good actually
and as far as protests go relatively
witty although perhaps somewhat
ill-timed
so here's a way of thinking about that
so
i've been discussing a series of images
with my wife and one of them is uh an
image of mary
and it's a very
it was a renaissance image that was
painted by many many people
and uh
it's funny i'm going to talk about the
divine feminine after that interruption
um
mary is often represented with her head
surrounded by stars and with her foot on
a serpent
on the world right and so well what is
that exactly that image well it's
something like
what is it to have your head in the
stars let's say
well you know
when you
i bought this cottage up north in in
northern canada and it's very dark up
there
and you can go on to the dock at night
and
it's dark enough so you can see the
milky way you know and it has to be
pretty dark before you can see the milky
way and it's very impressive you know
what that's like if you've you know to
see the night sky or maybe you see it
feel the same way when you see the grand
canyon or a remarkable waterfall or some
particularly beautiful scene or perhaps
you feel that way in a cathedral
more likely you feel that way when
you're listening to music that really
grips you right it's all the same
experience and experience of all and
it's way down low in your nervous system
like the orienting reflex it's it's not
a cognitive response precisely it's a
precognitive emotional response that's
that signifies
significance
and you look up at the night sky and it
fills you with a sense of awe but it
doesn't just do that you see it it
activates the
the impulse to imitate which is a very
deep
motivation in human beings we're
unbelievable mimics we mimic each other
all the time which is why we all use the
same words let's say
we're very good at embodying other
people's embodiments it's it's a
particular talent that human beings have
and we're so good at that that we
imitate all sorts of things that aren't
even human
and so then you
you view this expansive night sky and
a sense of awe fills you as you confront
the
infinite it calls to something inside of
you that can master the infinite
and that's a form of imitation right to
look into the darkest place
the most
wide
expanse possible
and to have something inside you respond
that's capable of dealing with that
that's that instinct to imitate
and that's calling the best out of you
and that's why you love doing that and
it isn't just that you love it is that
you cannot live without it you cannot
live without it
and i know so many of you atheist or
otherwise
you can't live without music
you think why can you not live without
music
and what is it calling to precisely you
know
that remarkable interplay of harmonious
patterns because that's what music is
and that's what the world is it's not
objects it's the harmonious interplay of
patterns and music reflects that and
then you warrant yourself
in your embodied
manner to those patterns and dance
along with the world and that revivifies
you and if you're particularly good at
well maybe you'll also attract a mate
and you want a mate that doesn't detect
attempt to dominate you sexually during
the introductory dance right you want a
mate who will play along with you and
match your movements to theirs so that
you can see that there's a harmonious
interplay
between the two of you as you meet in
play soul to soul if you can manage it
and everyone knows that
and that capacity that's called out in
the dance is the same capacity that's
called out by the night sky and it's the
same thing that's represented in those
byzantine churches
you look deep enough into
infinity and you find your destiny
and that destiny is everything you could
be
and we all know that because and this is
what men and women search for in each
other
you know if you're rejected by a woman
well why is she rejecting you
well maybe her judgment is off and that
would be very what would you say
convenient for you
but she's rejecting you because you are
not all that you could be and maybe not
even all that you need to be
and so that's a very painful rejection
and it causes all sorts of tension
between men and women but you know women
have a lot at stake in this game
and so they're looking for something
what powerful dominating brutal terrible
no
something perhaps capable of that
but even more important capable of
mastering it right and capable of
singing despite that
we all know that's true and the shame
that men feel when they're rejected by
women is precisely the shame
that they feel at knowing deep in their
heart that they have not lived up to
what they are capable of being
and that harsh judgment that women lay
on men which by the way is part of our
sexual evolution because we were shaped
by sexual selection which by the way is
the operation of consciousness on the
structures of matter at the most basic
possible level
well it's a terrible rejection but it's
a salutary rejection
and that process of differentiated
choice has shaped us into what we are
that action of consciousness
wanting the best from a potential
partner and selecting at least in part
on that basis
and men participate that in that too in
the meister singer manner you know men
aren't competing
for for dominance with each other
constantly in
in
in a
what zero-sum game to achieve sexual
dominance there's an element of that
right
because some things are a zero-sum game
but men are perfectly capable and more
than willing in fact to aggregate
themselves into skilled groups and to
celebrate the elevation of the most
skilled above all else
and so we see this cooperative venture
between men and women over the longest
run of possible time in producing some
refinement of the human spirit in
embodied form and we want that from
everyone we
require that from everyone we're
thrilled to the core of our soul when we
encounter it in a conversation or in a
course
or in a work of art
that calls to us in that manner
we need to know this increasingly we
need to know all this consciously you
know
we've acted it out we've produced images
to represent it it's it tugs at our
heartstrings it it manifests itself in
our dreams and our work of art our
literary works it's all lurking there in
some sense and it's not
the satanic power of corrupt
oppression not fundamentally
that's a far weaker force than that
which can overcome it
and everything around us would be
nothing but hell if that's all there was
and everything around us is not only
hell
you know for fragile and broken
creatures ignorant to the core
we don't do too badly and people are
capable of nobility especially under the
duress of suffering that's virtually
miraculous when you encounter it
and it's so heartening to see that and
you've seen it in the people that you
love when they're going through terrible
trials you know people become corrupt
and embittered by their catastrophes and
it's no wonder but
certainly in the main that's not the
fundamental human response the
fundamental human response is keep calm
and carry on you know
and and good on you for that so
well to sum up
let's say
we solve the power of perception with
divine word
that's how it is
and what does that mean well it means
truth
every word a prayer right every word a
groping to find a firm foundation to
stand on while you make your way through
life and
every time you hear a conversation of
that sort or hear yourself participating
in that prayerful process orienting
yourself to this highest uniting good
and using that to govern your utterance
it's it's bomb for the soul
yeah it's love that guides that and love
is the desire to work for the betterment
of all things
and that's the proper orienting response
we could say
and it's truth nested inside of that
and that's how it is and that's how it
should be and that's how it may forever
be
[Applause]
[Music]
you